try to guess which is okay ready
set go
[Laughter]
well now you can't bend your elbow i
think no i can't
i know what was weak spot
there
[Applause]
it's like 10 minutes 10 is back
oh my god exactly
oh beautiful
[Applause]
i think that's enough i want to get out
of this
fill a ping pong ball full of water and
we have this
massive syringe to do that
where did you get this thing
maybe halfway yeah
normal ball vs water ball try the ghost
which is similar
okay ready go oh
there's good spin
oh and it might bounce we're not even
gonna get
two shots on no no we'll get one rally
if we skip the serve
be like a volley
yeah let's fill it up the first dose
didn't have the desired effect so
it's time for injection number two feel
like
like a mad scientist
yep okay let's try it out bounce test
another two actually it might be a bit
different because now it has no air in
it it's only water so
i mean it could be it could be it could
be it could be but now
it sounds like a bouncy ball okay
okay
oh
oh i think it cracked yeah it cracked
yeah he's had enough we've also got a
lot of suggestions to play with the
frozen table tennis ball so
we're gonna put one of these in the
freezer and
try it out
[Music]
oh you received my surfboard yeah i
didn't receive yours
oh that's how it yeah so let's make a
bit harder sir now then
yeah i think we got it that's quite good
let's see how the frozen ball is doing
okay this is what happened
it just expanded and the ball couldn't
take it
okay maybe i make it it's melting really
oh
whoa oh that's so cool
you see that that looks so oh
that's cool okay we're gonna be fast
yeah this is melting quick
okay zero zero
surprise yeah wow that went pretty much
as expected
good matchup that was the shortest
challenge of the day
see you guys go and check out
go and check out pongfinity.store our
webstore we have
cool ping pong products
share this portable knit and
professional level ping pong balls
until next time